I thought it needs to do something
Oh the legs
oh the one to the plot ankles Anakin has
been around forever he's played in
dozens of tournaments repping Jack and
America even in the hardest moments he's
a fan favorite but right now he's North
America's greatest hope
Horace himself though and can win three
Mehcad Lana what an end they're the
perfect time to use that rage drive
getting the balcony brick drop in the
air aha ATL Anakin
representing radiance redbull and
Atlanta these days the Tekken world has
their eyes on only one place Pakistan so
it's easy to forget that we have some
incredible players back home as well and
it can started his journey with Tekken 3
so long ago that even he doesn't
remember it all that well but he was
instantly hooked man I had to be honest
when I once I started playing Tekken I
never stopped
I feel like I could have gone and
branched off and played all sorts of
different games but it was just Tekken
that I came back to the arcades playing
every single day he eventually graduated
from getting his ass beat at the local
arcades in Atlanta to dominating the
local scene and entering tournaments
well I remember the very first
tournament that I attended I was like 11
I saw just like an ad for a local
tournament and they arcade and I
definitely just I didn't know anything
about Camille fgc or communities I was
just a little kid playing at the arcade
I took second place against someone of
like the great ACL players and I kind of
like kickstart my my journey to a
competitive second it was like I was
hooked right from the moment that I went
to my first term I did so well and the
tournament scene made him fall in love
with Tekken even more it was the
beginning of the end of almost every
other aspect of his life all he wanted
to do was compete now Tekken wasn't the
biggest game in the fgc for a really
long time
it's sat in the shadow of Street Fighter
when it came to the competitive space
but that all started to change when MLG
started running
for Tekken 6 and Anakin well he jumped
at the opportunity it was the first time
that tekken really got that big esports
spotlight with a big prize pool and
everything and this is kind of beginning
of when we started to see major
tournaments that included not only the
best players from America but players
from Korea Japan all over the world are
starting to see it these tournaments as
worthwhile for them to over and maybe
went a little muddy before that point
Anakin was known on the local level but
it was his win at MLG Dallas that really
propelled him into the spotlight
I remember that tournament it was like
the best moment for me because it kind
of propelled me into like recognition
and on the international scale a lot
more people kind of took my character
seriously and kind of trained for that
and from that moment on that was kind of
like a big target at any tournament that
was also the moment when people started
taking his character jack more seriously
Jack wasn't a very popular pick back
then but it's what Anakin settled on
after having a bit of a crisis and he
make Jack look good Anakin developed a
reputation as one of North America's
best but his wins over Korean talent
were rare at a time when tech and
tournaments were declining prize pools
were going down which meant less travel
for the Korean players who defined the
game Tekken wasn't dying but it wasn't
exactly thriving until Tekken 7
tekken 7 was flashy it was exciting and
it had everything people were looking
for at a time where some fighting games
felt disappointing and anakin well
Anakin started the game off on the right
foot and rip again fall short and
blaming a spot on the ticket or his win
at combo breaker gave Anakin a qualifier
spot for the king of the Iron Fist
tournament which is Tekken's World
Finals that's not what Anakin wanted and
it can decided that he wanted to keep
playing he gave up his qualifying spot
and grinded his way back to the final I
felt like I would have just been living
myself if I was just at home and waited
for finals you know it's kind of sitting
on the Shelf a little bit yeah rusty and
it's dead I kind of like put it on a
line I guess it wasn't really that big
of a deal I think but it was really fun
to get all the tournaments perience
before the game even came out he might
not have won but he earned his spot a
second time after calling his shot and
that counts for a lot for the next
couple of years
Anakin maintained his reputation and one
of North America's best but as players
started traveling again the hometown
heroes started to slow down anybody
[Applause]
he wasn't placing poorly it just wasn't
up to his standards which means going
into Evo 2019 he wanted better from
himself he wanted more oh my goodness
Anakin just dashing in and out a rain
dance made him fight the bullet right
now to the office gone
a perfect he panics please I can't
believe it groovy to be the strongest
tree Nicholas one more hit and he gets
it and it can might not have won evo
2019 but he got as close as any North
American player has in years
tying Limoges place from the year before
I got to give it up etiquette third
place not too shabby hey you know that
is that the best in American has ever
done in watch it might have got third
last year - oh yeah you're right about
that
he took knee to the limit and left the
stage was the crowd chanting his name
and now Anakin is back in the finals and
this time he's number two on the
leaderboard right behind me the god of
Tekken and a tournament staffed with
players from Korea Pakistan and Japan
Anakin is North America's greatest hope
and he is not the kind of person to
settle for anything less thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]